-Welcome back to
The Tonight Show, everybody.
I'm Steve Higgins
and it's time to play...
♪♪
Well, well, well. Let's meet
our contestants. To my left,
he's an Emmy- and Tony-winning
actor
who stars in the new movie
"Beau Is Afraid,"
in theaters April 21st.
Give it up for Nathan Lane!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my goodness.
Brilliant. Nathan, your partner
this evening
is the host of NBC's
"The Tonight Show"
and Grammy -- oh, Grammy
Award-winning musician
Jimmy Fallon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my gosh.
Well, your first opponent
is a member
of the legendary Roots crew.
Say hello to Questlove!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
-He's just a member of
The Roots.
You won a Grammy.
-I did win a Grammy Award.
-Yeah, you did. Wow.
-Do you know what it's like
to win an award, Quest? Yeah.
-One day I'll find out, man.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-And Quest's partner stars in
the Apple TV+ series
"Schmigadoon!"
Season two premieres April 5th.
It's Dove Cameron!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The rules of the game
are very simple.
I will give
each of you a password
and then you are
to give a one-word clue.
That's one word only to get your
partner to guess the password.
The team with the most points
after four words wins.
First clue goes to Jimmy
and Questlove.
-Now, before we start, I'd like
to set some ground rules.
-Oh, boy.
-You know, I've played
many games with Jimmy
over the years,
and it always turns ugly.
-Oh, my God.
I'm very competitive.
-He starts out as
very happy-go-lucky,
"everything is awesome" Jimmy.
And it turns into
very competitive
and a lot of misplaced anger
Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-I do not do that.
-Which I find very triggering.
So I just wanted to say
as we watch
Western civilization
and democracy disintegrate
before our eyes,
a little game of "Password"
is not the most important
thing in the world
and that no matter
who wins or who loses,
you're still a very special boy
and we all love you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now let's play the [bleep] game,
Jimmy.
-Jimmy and Quest,
you got the first clue.
-The password is...
-Start us off.
-Oh, come on.
-Ooh!
-I'm in trouble already.
-No.
-It's me who's in trouble.
You sure you want to go first?
-Yeah. No, you first.
-Hmm.
Tulips?
-Tiptoe?
-Quest.
Worth 5 points.
-10, brah.
-Danny 10, brah.
Uh, I hope this is
the right color.
Yellow.
-Easter?
-No.
-What are the passwords
so far?
-Yellow and tulips.
-Flowers.
Um...
-Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes.
Yes. Say it. Say it.
-Holland?
-Yes. Holland.
Holland.
-Holland. For tulips.
-Really?
-Wow.
-No?
-Alright.
-You see what I'm talking about,
ladies and gentlemen?
He's already turned on me.
[ Laughter ]
Already.
-Holland! Holland!
-We got Holland. We got tulips.
-Tulips and flowers.
-Yeah.
-I've only heard this
in one song, and I hope you knew
this reference.
-Okay.
-Um...
And I hope we can pay
for the publishing.
♪ Flow-ers ♪
[ Laughter ]
-And the reference was lost
on the entire audience.
[ Sad tuba ]
-Shut up, tuba!
[ Laughter ]
-I honestly have no idea.
Spring?
-Spring. Spring.
-Springtime.
-Oh.
-Hitler.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Alright, score 0-0.
The word was "daffodil."
-Ah!
-The password is...
-Dove, you are first.
[ Audience ohhs ]
Oh, my God.
-What does that mean?
-Uh...
Starbucks?
-Nice.
-Grande?
-Ooh.
-I see how you got there.
You're getting excited.
You feel like we're going
to get this, right? Yeah.
-Frozen?
-[ Gasps ]
-Starbucks and frozen.
-Frappuccino?
-Oh!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow! Well, well.
-Yes!
Yabba-dabba-do!
-Oh, my God.
-Yabba-dabba-do!
-Quest and Jimmy.
-The password is...
-Questlove, why don't you
start us off this time?
-Okay. Okay.
-Got it?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm going to
throw this away.
I'm gonna throw this away.
-Alright.
-And we'll get it
on the third one.
-Good tactic.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Ants.
[ Audience "ohs" ]
-Oh.
Not aunts.
[ Laughter ]
Ants?
-Ants.
-First thing you think of ants.
-Oh, anthill.
-Oh, there we go.
-Oh, wait.
-Ants.
-I'm conjuring the spirit
of Betty White right now.
-Yes.
This is good. Do that.
Alright. Here we go.
-[ Deep voice ] Yogi.
-Oh.
-Bear?
-I was going to do that.
-You ready?
-You remember what I said,
right?
-Yeah, I remember. Ants.
It's in there. Yeah.
-And he said Yogi.
-Mm-hmm.
-Lunch.
-Picnic.
-Oh!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh!
Questlove predicted it.
He goes, "We're going to
get it in three."
-Yeah, that's a good strategy.
-Let me grab these guys.
-It's a barn burner.
-This barn is on fire.
-Oh, boy.
-Alright, Nathan.
-The password is...
-Nathan, you start us out.
[ Audience ohhs ]
Oh, my gosh.
-Uh...
-You feel confident.
I'm trying not to look
at the card.
-I want to see too. Oh.
-Um, uh...
-Does that count as a clue?
Yeah.
-Logan.
-Oh!
-Succession?
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, wow!
Oh, wow!
-Oh, my gosh!
-Wow.
-Wowee.
-You deserve that.
You deserve that.
-Wow!
-You deserve that.
-Goodness gracious.
-I'm exhausted.
-We are exhausted.
-My gosh.
Okay, there's one more.
This is the last clue.
Worth 1 billion points.
-Oh!
-Wow.
-The password is...
-Who's winning?
[ Laughter ]
-No one.
-No one?
-America. America's winning.
-So sad.
-Alright. Okay.
Sneeze!
[ Laughter ]
-Achoo!
-Yeah!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness!
Oh, whoa!
-My thanks to Dove Cameron,
Nathan Lane.
We're talking to Nathan
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.